welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and we have
some breaking news from Brandon Davis
and Vin Diesel about Thor for the
interview that just dropped with the
actor states that the Guardians will
indeed be in Thor for which will be
directed by Taika Waititi before we get
into the story make sure you subscribe
to the channel for videos like this
every day and click the bell button to
never miss a video
after James Gunn was fired by Disney
last year things have kind of been up in
the air regards to where we would be
going with the characters and we did not
know whether the Guardians would be in
the film or not it did seem like the
necessary steps to take for the next
film with the way things were left at
the end of Avengers endgame however
there wasn't really any confirmation
until today when promoting his new movie
bloodshot diesel cold Davis the
following the war will also the director
talk to me about how Thor will
incorporate some of the guardians of the
galaxy which would be very interesting
nobody knows but maybe I should miss it
ok so there's a lot that we can take
from that firstly diesel says that they
will be incorporated into the movie
which could mean a number of things it's
likely that they will be there at the
start but the group could jet off to go
and see someone else however his next
statement is very interesting on how it
may actually flesh out their role Diesel
did tell Davis that Groot would evolve
beyond what we've seen him as before
instead of going back to the group we
met in the first film you will actually
become alpha Groot now what this means
for the future we don't know but it is
possible that he could end up becoming
king Groot or the leader of other groups
and this is why he's the Alpha so the is
guardians of the galaxy are going ahead
and already the film looks stacked not
only is it dealing with Jane's return
but we also learned last week that
Christian Bale would be featuring as the
film's villain though we don't know who
that is yet the fact that group will be
evolving in several ways showcases to me
that the guardians may be in the movie
for the duration in order to allow this
to happen to the character I don't know
whether they will be in the entire thing
but it will be interesting to see Taika
Waititi handling the characters after
return down guardians of the galaxy vol
3
incants departure Gunners have cause
back on board with the project now and
yeah I'm very
excited to see how things would be
handled going forward we did here in the
recent plot leaks which yes spoiler
alert if you don't want anything ruined
that the Guardians would feature in the
film but that they would depart quite
early on after being bested by the
villain of the piece take these leaks
with a pinch of salt but it does seem
likely that this is what the movie could
line up with I am of course interested
to hear your thoughts on the news and
what role you think they will have in
the film coming below and let me know
and if you want a more in-depth
breakdown of the Marvel movies and make
sure you check out some of the insane
details that we spotted in Avengers age
of Ultron which is going to be linked at
the end we go over some of the best bits
of trivia in the film so it's definitely
worth checking out if you want in a war
you want to support the channel from as
little as 99 cents a month then please
click the join button below
we massively appreciate you it and as a
thank you you get access to content
early you want to come chat us after the
show either follow us at definition
whitey or click the discord link in the
description below those are the best
ways to keep up-to-date with heavy
spoilers so hopefully we see it over
there very soon this is a channel for
people who are super into superheroes so
if that's the kind of thing you like it
subscribe thank you for taking the time
to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you